I run a meetup group in New York City
and one of the things that we do
whenever we have a speaker come up in
order to welcome the speaker is a person
we ask the person say their name we all
say hi now one thing is that room over
there is really packed but there's a
glass wall here i'm going to say hi my
name is James Powell and all of you are
going to say as little out as you can hi
James loud enough to make all those
people be like what is going on over
there so are you ready do you need to
take a breath everybody's ready so I'm
gonna say hi my name is James you need
to say okay I start the talk hi everyone
my name is James Powell yeah they looked
over so there we go so we're at hi-data
London today is Sunday June twenty-first
2015 if you have any questions or any
complaints about this talk you can
follow me on Twitter and tweet at me at
don't use this code if you want to email
me you can email me at James that don't
use this code calm if you want to read
my my old blog you can read it at
seriously that don't use this code it is
a pun okay we keep going with this and
if you want to find me on IRC I'm d UTC
on I RTC for don't use this code and
sometimes if that handle is not
available I'm d UTC h4 don't use this
code hoss from Texas I run New York City
python meetup group it's the world's
largest and most active python meetup
group we haven't had an event in a while
but we're going to get started again
quite soon we have a huge data science
community in New York so if any of you
find yourselves on the other side of the
ocean please look us up come and turn 21
/ events we have a lot of great speakers
a lot of great organizers a lot of cool
stuff happening in New York we have
things like office hours every Tuesday
and we have study groups on Saturdays
and Sundays and we have headlined events
on thursdays i also work with numb focus
to help put on events like the event
that we're attending here we organize
multiple PI data events every year in
fact none of the London local team know
this but if you don't include the Google
day this is actually pie that a 10 and
we totally missed out on the branding of
this being PI data X but that's what it
is so we've done 10 PI that event so
are not including the first google day
that was like 40 people if you don't
know about numb focus one of the things
that I'm tasked with doing is reminding
people what num focus is it's the 501 C
3 so the united states federal nonprofit
that funds projects like ipython
notebook like julia data science
projects we fund you know numpy we've on
syfy a lot of the tools that you're
using day-to-day are funded by num focus
it's also the organization that hosts
and organizes and puts on the PI data
conference series this year we had pie
that at Dallas in April we have pi data
London right here we're doing PI data
Seattle next month I think we already
have a thousand people signed up to
attend it's going to be a huge event at
Microsoft headquarters and we're going
to be doing PI data in New York I don't
know if these dates are quite official
but by the time the video comes out
these dates will probably be totally
available so we have you know these four
big Python events every year and we've
also done an event in Berlin and event
in Paris and there's talk of doing
events throughout Europe there's some
talk during this event about doing a PI
data and maybe Spain applied that on
Amsterdam so you have plenty of
opportunities to see excellent speakers
like the guy next door you guys are
supposed to light self-deprecating humor
this is okay see I was telling emmalin
everybody assumes that i merit that
American humor must always be backed by
a laugh track so maybe maybe we need
that so about me I I like to give talk
to these events I speak about things
like Python software engineering
applications the quant finance I have a
finance background data science machine
learning these are the areas of my own
interest this year I've spoken at PI
Tennessee I gave a lightning talk at
PyCon of Montreal I spoke at an our
conference I have a friend who I usually
invite to speak of Python conferences so
he invited me to speak in an hour
conference got to mix it up a bit I
spoke in dallas at pi that at dallas i
spoke with the open data science
conference last month in boston where at
PI data london here and if you'd like to
see me again this year i'll be in
seattle for pi data seattle i'll
probably be at pi Gotham the or the
conference that we're organizing in New
York I'll probably be a PI Texas I'm
from Texas and then PI that again so
there's plenty of opportunities to see
or not see my talks as you choose and
also ODS see at the end of the year in
San Francisco so just to preface this
some of you may have seen my talk last
year on generators and this is a topic
that I have been talking about for a
very long time in fact one of the very
first talks ever gave was at Python in
New York in 2012 and it was called
generators and co routines for stream
data processing I then took that talk
and rewrote it and presented it at PI
data Silicon Valley in 2013 then I
presented that talk in addition to two
other talks at PI data Bossa in 2013 and
then I presented to those talks I let
one of them spin off to my co-presenter
and presented another generation talk at
pi that in New York in 2013 I took that
talk and I swear to you I actually added
some new material when I presented it in
London then I presented it again I just
changed the name for Silicon Valley
because I thought we need something new
in here and I couldn't really put in the
effort to do anything but change the
name actually I changed all the slides
but we presented again in Silicon Valley
then in Berlin then in New York again
and then suddenly this year I decided
let me bring you something fresh so here
you have a new talk called integration
with the vernacular I presented it at
Dallas and here at PI that attend in
London so this is my 10th PI data talk
or my temp I that appearance and my 15th
pie that a talk so as you can see all of
you should for next year submit a talk
to PI data London they'll accept anybody
that's it yep so this talk is called
integration with the vernacular and it's
about the numpy approach this is not a
features talk like generator it's it as
the generator talk evolved it turned
from being something more about this is
what it is these are the features is how
you use it talking about you know code
and just going through documentation and
things like that and it evolved towards
being a talk about conceptualizations
about modeling about how you can use
this tool in order to structure a
program in order to rethink the way the
computations are structured and the as
that talk evolved I realized that what I
was most interested in is was these
high-level conceptualizations of what
we're doing we're writing
for now I know we're I'm presenting in
front of a data science audience and for
the most part data science audiences
don't really care that much about
software code it just happens to be what
they need to do to get the job done and
for many data scientists if they could
do analysis by just banging two rocks
together they would because I don't care
about code they care about the data
science they care about machine learning
still I would assert that there's a lot
of importance in terms of how the tools
are used how you structure computations
around the tools about understanding how
to build actual pieces of software these
these artifacts that we dismiss oh you
know it's just writing software I think
that's actually a very important thing I
think that's a science and an
engineering unto itself this talk like
like many of these high-level thought
leader type talks this talk is supported
by an analogy but rather than be labor
mathematical analogies of which I think
there are many I decided to be labor an
entirely different ten substantially
more absurd analogy there's a lot of
editorializing in this talk to I will
say however that as a serious note I
would like to convey to the audience
that engineering is a fundamentally
human approach and then everything about
this talk everything I'm trying to
convey to you is that our job
independent of whether we're software
programmers or quants or data scientists
our jobs are usually to generate some
artifact that supplants or that supports
some human process and that there's a
lot of work that goes around generating
that when we have application of theory
but there's also a lot of consideration
about political consequences in terms of
how the organization internally works
there's a lot of thought about how code
evolves over time within an organization
there's a lot of there's a lot more to
it than just the raw computer science
fundamentally this talk is about
creating a language or a framework for
understanding and discussing software
development from an engineering
perspective we could for example say
that when we write software we're
constructing an algebra you can think
that a piece of software is really some
domain in which you have some
qualifications on the input data and
some qualifications on the codomain that
has some sort
properties that you assert over the
domain and some certain relations and
operations that you assert over objects
in that domain and then you apply it to
objects you've never seen before and if
you've written that software well the
software those properties still hold so
for example when you learn math and
school you learn math over numbers that
you can fit into your head and you never
ask well I learned that for example
addition is associative but what if i
give it really big numbers presumably
when we write software we write software
with some inputs in mind and then we
apply two inputs we never seen and we
assume that certain properties and
certain operations that we've encoded
still hold on input to never seen that's
what I think software really is and
that's a mathematic knology we could
take instead what I wanted to share with
you is an analogy that has really stuck
with me that was born in my previous
life so I actually have a engineering
background but I did my undergraduate
degree in Asian Studies and so what I'm
going to provide to you is a very
interesting analogy that stuck with me
that describes and conceptualize is
something that I've seen when using
numpy one a very important qualification
is I'm going to criticize numpy a lot
here but numpy is actually really great
it's a very useful tool it's something
that actually gets real work done for a
lot of people but it's a tool that was
born many years ago in what you might
consider to be the pre-modern era or the
pre contemporary era so just one last
warning this talk is totally inscrutable
so let me start by going back to
nineteen eleven so in 1911 there was a
May fourth movement in China remember
China was an imperial state until 1911
from some 2000 BC until 1911 it was
ruled by a series of Imperial dynasties
and in 1911 there was this first move
towards republicanism towards actually
destroying the dynasties and forming a
state as a modern political entity well
the mate fourth movement is this mix of
a political and social and literary
movement in 1919 in Beijing there were a
group of authors that are very closely
associated with in May fourth movement
some of the authors on the screen you
shouldn't Muldoon loud Nicole also and
if you read if
you read their works or if you're
familiar with any sort of contemporary
Chinese that are two rather modern
Chinese literature these names come up
and one thing that really typifies this
literary movement was the use of the
vernacular this is something that that
is a little bit odd to an
english-speaking language but if you if
you look really closely prior to
nineteen nineteen any literary Chinese
was written in classical Chinese it was
written in a dialect that nobody spoke
so just imagine if until nineteen
nineteen everybody who's writing
anything in English wrote in
Shakespeare's English and that's the
situation that they had in China prior
to nineteen prior to the May fourth
movement and these authors amongst
others promoted the use of the
vernacular promoted the use of the
language that people actually speak when
writing things like short stories when
we're actually putting pen to paper when
we talk about classical Chinese and
literary Chinese there's many there's
many different terms that many different
terminologies many different things we
can talk about but one thing that
typifies classical Chinese is the use of
idiomatic expressions and this is
something that we see in very formal
dialects of English as well in a
collective English as well which is set
phrases that we don't really have any
way to to break down that we just kind
of just percolate down to us and this is
a very very common thing in Chinese and
it's something that you see a lot you
have these four character idiomatic
expressions and these four character
idiom attic expressions are something
that originated in texts that were
written hundreds of years ago and are
integrated into everyday speech and
they're very poorly integrated everyday
speech at one very common example of
this is falling leaves return to the
roots this is a very common idiomatic
expression that Eddie speaker of Chinese
will know it's in Chinese it's law yet
gueguen and it means it's usually used
to metaphorically refer to things like
when you get older you want to retire
back to where you came from just this
notion but the very interesting about
this idiomatic expression despite any
speaker of Chinese having run across and
maybe even use this in everyday speech
is that if you look at where it came
from it came from a text from a very
long time ago came from a song dynasty
the records of the transmission of the
lamp and I actually looked it up and
it's very easy to find this on google by
searching these phrases and you can see
here's the actual phrase that it came
from and when you look at the actual
phrase it where it came from you can see
that and here's the actual text and it's
a discussion between you know two people
about a top about this but when you look
at it you can actually see some very
interesting things we have a situation
in which some very common idiom an
idiomatic expression that somebody is
using in everyday speech originates and
a text that nobody's ever written and
sorry nobody's ever really read and
nobody's really ever source from
directly and it's just part of the
language it just appears there and this
is somewhat familiar to us but not
really and then the closest that we get
in English is Shakespeare and the the
the house Shakespeare has permeated
Shakespeare's language this is very
appropriate for our audience but how
Shakespeare's language has permeated the
use of English so North by Northwest in
our media we have movies we have books
that that draw from Shakespeare North by
Northwest what dreams may come murder
most foul these are all phrases from
Shakespeare Star Trek 6 the undiscovered
country is also part of it from
Shakespeare but the weird thing is if
you look at this original phrase in
Chinese you can see that what we say
what we say a modern Chinese is lawyer
gueguen the falling leaves return to the
roots but in the actual original phrase
where it came from these two characters
are swapped it's actually yeah lock
wagon and this is not a it's not a
terribly uncommon thing a Chinese to
have these kind of character swapping
but it's interesting that you have this
phrase that exists and this slightly
more compatible to how you think about
it in a modern sense actually originated
as a completely different phrase and it
comes out as you know you can see that
this is this has been divorced from its
original context you have this way of
speaking that is totally unrelated
nobody knows where it came from nobody
knows the original phrase whenever I
provide in the in the last three talks
that I've given I've spoken to people
who had background in classical Chinese
and even they even they are surprised to
say oh actually that's how the phrase
originally looked so you can see that we
have this weird separating from the
original source text we do have this a
little bit in English so in Shakespeare
generates a lot
of this so we have forgone conclusion
which came from Othello we have sea
change which came from The Tempest we
have to send somebody packing which came
from Henry the sixth we have and we have
we have a number of these that we don't
even unpack right we don't even think
what does it mean to send somebody back
what does it mean a sea change these are
metaphors that that come to us but we
never really interrogate where they came
from we just try to integrate them into
speech and for the most part it comes
out as being fairly well integrated
however the interesting thing about
Chinese is these are very poorly
integrated with the Chinese vernacular
so if you take a phrase like this
proposal is not guaranteed to go through
in Chinese and this is what it would be
in Chinese you'll see that there's
actually a four character proverb right
here and this this conveys the meaning
of guaranteed now one thing to note is
that Chinese as a language is very
isolating it lacks inflectional
morphology which means that when as
you'd expect you can't really change the
character so when you want to build
Chinese you don't you don't have verb
inflections you don't anything like that
you just kind of put the pieces together
and so what that allows us to do at
least for a non Chinese speaking
audience is to take a sentence like that
and actually break it down word by word
so for this sentence this literally
means this this means proposal this
means is not this means guaranteed and
this means to go through well this thing
right here is a four character proverb
and it's just integrated right into that
as an adverbial phrase right and you can
see we have this marker here which
indicates it's in a verbal phrase but
you have this for character proverb
smacked right in the middle of a
sentence that comes from some source
that nobody's ever learned that just
screams at you it's an indivisible
entity that just screams at you this is
not this is not modern vernacular it's
not just a word it's not just an adverb
it's a set phrase with an idiomatic
meaning and if we actually look it up we
can see it comes from some source text
and the source text that it comes from
it's not even written this way it's
actually written completely differently
the last two characters are completely
different so the so the idiom that we're
using that we attribute to this original
source text isn't even what was in the
original source text they have this very
weird integration with the vernacular
well this is something that has stuck
with me for a very long time because
it's a very
it's a very odd thing it's a very odd
thing to in Chinese say a sentence and
have this kind of weird ancient language
pop up in the middle of it and then to
immediately be drawn to that as a set
phrase and to have no way to break it
down or integrate it into that and when
I started to really start using numpy
heavily I started get the same sense the
programs that i was writing had some
portion that was vernacular python that
was idiomatic python that was oh the
kind of Python that you know when i read
pep eight and i'm supposed to write and
then suddenly in order to write good
numpy code i'm suddenly combining these
these in these indivisible objects from
this very ancient style of communication
for some background for those of you who
don't know what numpy is it is of course
the premier library and python for
numeric computing it's the basis for
tools like scifi for pandas or
scikit-learn but fundamentally what it
is is the ndarray if you really look
into numpy and you try and see what it's
all about you might say well it's a
combination of numerical algorithms and
some data structures like matrix or in
verses or you might say it's you know
things like FFT and you know these these
these algorithms and these approaches
for signal analysis or you but but
really fundamentally numpy breaks down
to just a numpy ndarray there really is
it's numpy ndarray and then a bunch of
stuff on top of it and a bunch of
additions that are useful for specific
use cases but it really comes down to
this ndarray and the ndarray is just
some structure that allows you to
broadcast operations so when you take
this you multiply by 10 it broadcasts
that to every element it's some
structure that allows you to do things
like fancy indexing it's some structure
that has a specific machine type so now
we're getting somewhere kind of weird
because we've never talked about machine
types in Python right nobody ever says
oh we have a number here is this an
inter along has anyone ever wondered if
you're using an impasse on to an int
object or a long object or both separate
objects right but you have automatic
promotion and for the most part you know
if you're doing things that heavy loops
you might wonder why is this loop slow
when the numbers get a little bit bigger
but even in Python 3 there's no
separation between object and long
object anymore right so we're big
thing to worry about things in numpy
that are completely foreign to people
who are writing normal Python code not
only is this some innocent machine type
is it in 64 it's not even saying in
verse as long it's telling you the exact
number of bits in that int right and in
Python 3 look they're going in the
opposite direction where we're no longer
really distinguishing between floats and
integers right you do your division and
you division automatically generates a
float for you because it's we're trying
to create this more human friendly
numerical system and we don't want to
have to deal with well 3/2 is actually
one because it's truncating because
that's what happens and see when you
have in strong cating and that's how the
operation is defined on C pythons moving
the opposite direction whereas numpy
still stuck in this world and what you
worry about details like the machine now
of course the reason you do that is
because this is what allows numpy to
perform the way it does numpy is a
constrained computation environment
numpy is an environment in which you say
numpy i'm going to follow your rules and
i'm going to do a bunch of stuff for you
like i'm going to tell you exactly the
machine types i want to operate on i'm
going to assert certain things to you
implicitly not just the types but i'm
going to implicitly assert things like
the entities being independent of each
other so think about a numpy ndarray
it's just a big block of memory and the
elements inside of it are basically
memory managed by numpy and the
operations on them are completely
defined by numpy so certain things like
interrelations between the entities or
not expressible an umpire you can't say
this is an array and this number in this
array depends on this number in this
right here that all has to be done by
mechanisms outside of numpy and as a
consequence by constraining yourself
into this computation domain numpy could
do things potentially like automatic
vectorization when you do a broadcasting
on numpy there's no reason why numpy
can't multiply all those numbers in
parallel because it knows that there's
no interdependencies there because
you've given it this very restricted
domain in which certain assumptions can
hold and so for example what you can do
with numpy is you can take this this
construct this restricted domain and you
can perform operations and you can you
can take these high level building
blocks in this restricted domain to
perform operations and generate
meaningful computations so here we have
something like computing
wait a volume-weighted average price a
very very very trivial very basic
exercise you might do in Python I mean
rather in finance you have a set of data
set of closes and a set of volumes and a
numpy to express this computation you
have an average function which is this
big indivisible building block and you
have no idea what it really does under
the covers you give it the closes and
you give it the weights and it goes off
and it does all these computations and
how it implements those computations you
don't care it's almost declarative in a
sense and whatever numpy does internally
it doesn't matter in fact there was a
talk yesterday by one of the pie pie
developers romain about how he talked
where he talked about integrating with
numpy by embedding a sea python
interpreter into pie pie and that's
actually probably a fairly useful thing
you could do because as long as all the
computations stay within numpy it's good
enough so you could have all your
computation stay within your host C
Python interpreter and then once you
need a result you just have across the
interpreter battery back at the pie pie
well that's the style of writing that we
use for numpy we have this happen a lot
in umph I mean every if we want to do
something like an exponential moving
average it would just be the exact same
thing we take a convulsion and we take
our two inputs and we construct these
computations by these large building
blocks and all of the real details of
what the computation does internally or
handle by numpy this is a distinct mode
of computation because there are other
computation styles or other
methodologies for that like that are a
little bit more integrated one example
of them is what you may see these kind
of graph computing environments and what
what happens with these graph computing
environments is there's a desire to not
have to bend people to the style of well
I'm going to I'm going to do all of
these manipulations these numbers and
then I'm going to get them ready for an
ump I'm gonna stick them to an end erm
to do the operation the any drain and
pull them out the other side instead we
want to integrate that into the rest of
our software code base so you end up
with things that look like this you have
for example to calculate the market
value for portfolio you have some class
that represents some node in the
calculation that that total portfolio
value is the sum of the individual
values for every position and then for
each position that's another node in
this graph and the value of it is its
size times its price you assume that
everything is linear and
then for that position maybe it's a bond
so you say the price is a dirty price
and the dirty price of the clean price
press some accrual and you construct
this note of the computation and then
you can do some neat things with that
because you can say oh instead of
memorizing we can just say if we want to
do something like perturbative risk we
can identify exactly the nodes which
change and then recompute without having
to recompute things which aren't
affected by these small perturbative
changes to the leaves but it's a very
different approach because when you
start to look at this code you'll see
that in many cases there's a desire to
integrate these computations with the
rest of the application with the rest of
the environment so in our bond class you
won't only have a price in a dirty price
but you'll start to have things which
don't even relate to the computation
like you'll have the registration type
whoever's calculating the price of the
bond doesn't care if it's public or
private then that's a detail that
somebody in settlements cares about this
there's a detail that may be one of the
traders cares about but given a specific
price for the bond the computation is
really is really completely separate
from that in fact think about how many
domains where almost all of the work and
providing a computation for that domain
just devolves to some matrix operations
and when you're dealing with those major
operations you don't even think about
the units on the matrix operations just
do this decomposition do this
multiplication there that's the result
and that's that's a that's more or
that's more relatable to the numpy
approach than this integrated
development approach where you try and
say well let's try to holistically model
this object in a very naturalistic
fashion and also layer the computations
into that unfortunately one consequence
of this constrained approach is that
numpy does not integrate very well into
idiomatic Python Berra mine numpy was
created before something before you
could even say an idiomatic Python
existed what we consider to be nice
about Python things like decorators
things like generators things like
descriptors things like the class
structure didn't really exist until
fairly recently things that make Python
are more than just a wrapper on top of C
did not exist until fairly recently and
as a consequence you could you could
perhaps a tribute numpy spore
integration to Python
to it preceding the evolution of these
things in Python right but I'll show you
some some very specific conflicts 11
very specific thing is if you read Pepe
they say write your code like this don't
write your code like this they say if
you want to see if a sequence has
elements you do if not sequence not if
length sequence and find that's perfect
in Python here's a little piece of code
if you want to see if this is empty you
say FX s and the first time you try this
on an umpire in the array what happens
you get this obscure error message the
truth value of an array with more than
one element is ambiguous use any or all
and what does this mean well it means
that trying to determine truth or false
so this is trying to broadcast that you
end up with a bunch of truths or falses
and you have to see if all of them are
true or altum or false and what it turns
out is if you wanted to have a piece of
code that could interact with both a
Python list and a numpy ndarray without
having to know what they are just saying
these are abstract iterable abstract
container types you'd actually have to
write it in this fashion it's the only
way that you could have it transparently
deal with both a numpy list and I'm pie
sorry a Python listen um pai ndarray
without having to know either one except
this is explicitly not idiomatic Python
you're told do not write your code in
this fashion but it goes a little bit
deeper than that numpy even has these
weird boundaries or interacts
unexpectedly with standard Python
mechanisms for example we're all
familiar with generators in fact I've
given somewhere between 73 and 422 talks
on generators but the thing is when you
stick a generator into numpy ndarray you
get this and you can make the argument
that it may be ambiguous what you mean
when you put a Jenner in turn on paddy
array and there's no good choice and
I'll accept that now say maybe there is
no good choice but you're still going to
be a little bit surprised when you try
and stick a generator into numpy ndarray
and it gives you an array with one
element in an element generator you're
going to be a little bit what is this
you'd expect it to at least try to
exhaust the generator and you might say
well and you can understand well maybe
we don't know if that I generator is
exhaustible and there's many many
arguments you can make for why it is
this way but you're still going to be
surprised and you're still going to find
that integrating code that uses
generators and code that uses numpy it
still is not very fluent the numpy style
doesn't interact with rich Python
objects either so one example of that is
network X has a very nice thing where if
you construct a graph and network X and
you want to do things like add weights
to the graphs you add a keyword argument
and you can add weights of these graphs
and then you could do things like you
could do you know Dijkstra's algorithm
and dikes drag them to take into the to
account those weights you can attach a
little bit of an additional associate
information with this structure that
network X is itself maintaining for you
there's not really an equivalent for
that in numpy for example if you wanted
to write a video game and that you want
to use numpy to very quickly perform
computations on the monsters in your
video game you'd have to take those
monster objects that may include some
other details that are necessary for the
video game like their hip points and
their damage you'd have to extract each
of those individually into numpy and dra
perform those computations in numpy and
then get them out the other side because
you don't want to put a Python up you
probably don't want to put a Python
object in ndarray you don't get any
benefits from that in fact I'll show you
that there's some very dangerous things
that can happen but also you lose the
ability to add additional information on
top of the limits of what numpy can
itself can itself model so one very
common example is in Python we want to
sort a list say we want to sort this
list by its absolute value in Python we
have a very very nice very aromatic way
to do it we pass it a keyword function
and suddenly this list is sorted by its
magnitude so you can see independent of
the sign the numbers are sorted how do
we do that numpy we have to go back to
our swartz and transform our decorate
sort on decorated do it there's no
equivalent an umpire in fact a numpy
what we have to do is you have to take
this array put it into a different
domain by broadcasting absolute value
over that then bring it back into our
original domain using org sort and then
fancy index on that so you can see we
have to actually do a domain
transformation to do something as simple
as sorting a numpy ndarray by some by
some arbitrary predicate there's no
there's no api for that and this is this
is literally a short scene transform you
can see it's a domain transform to go
from this restriction domain that numpy
provides to a domain that it's amenable
to the computation you want to prove you
want to do and then back into the other
original domain as opposed to idiomatic
Python which is just I mean it's they
say this is absurd let's just try to
keep keyword phone
we can sort by anything we want we can
add or we can we can we're given hooks
to model that I don't have slides for
this but another another conversation
came up yesterday about the limits for
overriding d types in numpy and how
there's no hooks for implementing custom
types and doing numpy computations over
custom types and if you're interested in
that topic specifically please talk to
Jeffrey backers in the audience he was
the originator for this very very useful
point i think really drives home how
numpy is just kind of this weird little
war very useful but weird little wart
that sits in the middle of what we're
supposed to consider idiomatic Python
one thing that we can do with python is
we can do things like nice fancy
indexing except if we try and put a if
we try and put a rich Python object like
a dictionary into it it totally breaks
down right the numpy has no way to model
the computation using item item getting
right there's no way to figure out how
to do fancy indexing with that and so
you end up with you end up with what's
originally a very nice syntax for
dealing strictly within the numpy domain
you can do 0 comma 0 strictly with a
numpy domain and get exactly that
element there's no way for an umpire to
model the computation of 0 comma 0 where
it does something on top it does
something through the numpy domain into
less constrained python domain and in
fact one thing I wanted to show to you
before I finish up is there are even
weirder corner cases so I wrote this
script on a whim a couple weeks ago and
what it does is it takes a command line
and it runs it with you limit until it
stops failing so it tells you the
minimum amount of virtual memory that
you need to successfully get an exit
code of zero from some some program and
I use this to analyze how much memory of
Python program needs so I run a Python
program figure out what's the minimum
out of memory it needs then I'll run
things in loops and I'll see is the
garbage collector operating correctly
and so if you do that for a piece of
code that looks like this it creates two
numpy and the arrays creates a circular
reference between the two of them and
then sticks an extra Python object in
one of them and then garbage collect it
what you'll see is that this will run
two times and then fail if you have a
circular reference between two numpy and
diares and
of those ND arrays contains a PI object
when those two ND arrays get garbage
collected they will not garbage collect
the additional Python object there's a
memory leak here and that's you can see
in this case it's a fairly serious
memory leak because even with 113
megabytes of memory this falls over
pretty quickly and the reason for that
there's certainly a reason for that I
mean the strictly well the the I'll show
you the same case before I show you the
reason for that the same case with a
Python normal a normal Python array and
you can change this runs forever just
runs red with a normal Python array so
this is a memory leaking in numpy it's
not a very serious memory because I
don't think a lot of people are sticking
pure python objects and NT arrays
there's not a lot of benefit that you
gain from it and so nobody's really put
the time or effort into looking you know
to try and fixing this and the cause of
it's very simple the reason for this is
if you look into the code for the array
object they don't implement TP traverse
or TP clear so when the garbage
collector tries to collect a numpy
ndarray it doesn't then collect
everything the numpy ndarray has a
reference to so it's a fairly small
thing there's probably a reason why they
didn't implement this because it's very
low hanging thing but what you can see
is that even the simplest thing of
embedding pure python objects in an tra
is it's awkward it's unusual it kind of
breaks and so this is you know what I
when I started to really start using
numpy very heavily I was like this is
very similar to the feeling that I get
in Chinese when I'm dealing with these
idiomatic expressions I have two
languages pure python and numpy and they
can co-exist but it's very obvious when
when I see both of them and I'll see a
piece of code and I'll say okay this is
the part that's appearing on pie code
and this is the part that's a pure
python code and they don't really
intermingle there's no way to cross that
boundary and there's a domain
transformation necessary in order to go
from one style to the other so I hope
you enjoyed this very belabored analogy
this was integration with the vernacular
I'm James pawan we're at PI data thank
you so much
you